Joe Biden has made another cabinet selection.
It's a very important one because it is the
secretary of Health and Human Services who
will be coming in during a global hundred
year pandemic.
And it turns out that Joe Biden has selected
someone who has long supported Medicare for
all.
This is very interesting.
It's a big deal.
And it is Xavier Becerra, who has been chosen
to lead Joe Biden's Department of Health and
Human Services now back in 2017, when when
he was also California attorney general, as
he still is, Becerra said he would, quote,
absolutely support a Medicare for all plan.
Becerra will be leaving his post as California
attorney general.
He will be a huge part of fighting the coronavirus
pandemic.
He will be a very welcome replacement to the
clownish Trump secretary of HHS, Alex Azar,
who is just a wild Trump brownnoser.
Now, from the standpoint of identity, there
is another first, Xavier Becerra would be
the first Latino to run HHS.
We're expecting more more health related announcements
from Joe Biden very, very soon.
We found out about some of them I mentioned
already.
Secretary of HHS will be Xavier Becerra at
the CDC.
It will be Rochelle Walensky, the Mass General
Hospital chief of infectious disease here
in Boston.
Surgeon general will be Dr. Vivek Murthy,
who was also Barack Obama's surgeon general.
So these are solid choices, qualified people.
Now, I admit what does not make sense to me
about choosing Xavier Becerra for secretary
of HHS is that he does lack experience in
the area of health and medicine.
He's a lawyer now.
There's a counterpoint to that.
Now, it's great that Xavier Becerra has supported
Medicare for all.
I see a lot of Bernie people who like the
choice for that reason.
But he does lack experience in the field of
medicine.
On the other hand, he has been front and center
as a lawyer fighting for Obamacare.
And as I imagine we will see as soon as Joe
Biden is sworn in, Republicans go right back
to let's get rid of Obamacare, let's get rid
of Obamacare, even though we have no replacement
in that sense, Becerra is a good choice.
But remember that Biden doesn't support Medicare
for all anyway.
But he does want to expand the Affordable
Care Act to include a public option.
And Becerra has experience defending the ACA
in legal settings.
And the the other important aspect of this
is that the truth is that secretary of HHS,
you're not really making medical decisions.
You're really an executive managing the apparatus
of health and Human Services.
And in that sense, there's no way to argue
that Becerra is unqualified.
Now, hilariously, there are some Republicans
who have immediately said Becerra is a radical.
He's a he's a radical.
We can't we can't have him running HHS.
And, of course, you know, those those guidelines
for what counts as radical at this point have
been completely khatuna fired by the right.
This also, by the way, take Xavier Becerra
off the list to be the replacement for Kamala
Harris, whose Senate seat will.
Be vacated when she becomes vice president,
and that's another story which we'll be covering.
And lastly, there is a good chance that Basara
will have a tough confirmation fight in the
Senate.
I think he will be confirmed because ultimately
he's completely qualified, but I think it
has the potential to get quite ugly.
Let me know what you think about the selection.
I'm on Twitter at
David Pakman.
I'd love
to hear from you.